This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to name anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请收听
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。成群的互联网侦探花了一番功夫才揭露出一个令人不安的规律。还有两个男人也经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇特现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 2%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. This topic has been a long time coming. It has been on my list of things that I really want to talk about for a while. And today we are finally getting around to doing it. We're going to be talking about the psychology of hobbies and how essential they are, not just for your well-being, but for this decade of life, I think personally, that hobbies are.
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. This topic has been a long time coming. It has been on my list of things that I really want to talk about for a while. And today we are finally getting around to doing it. We're going to be talking about the psychology of hobbies and how essential they are, not just for your well-being, but for this decade of life, I think personally, that hobbies are.|||相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。宝贝，相信我，请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界何处。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析你二十几岁的心理学。这个话题酝酿很久了。它一直在我的待聊清单上，我想谈论它已经有一段时间了。今天我们终于要开始聊这个了。我们将讨论爱好的心理学，以及它们有多么重要，不仅对你的身心健康，而且对这十年的生活来说也是如此，我个人认为，爱好
just as important as our friendships during our 20s. But despite that, we really do struggle, you and I, both of us can acknowledge that we struggle to devote the necessary time to them, to doing our hobbies. We wish that we had more kind of things that we love to do in our free time. For me personally, I feel like I collect hobbies almost like their trinkets. Like I have so many hobbies on rotation that I adore and then I love doing. but I don't always get the chance to actually do them and, you know, I'll drop them every now and again and then pick them back up like six months later. And what I've really begun to realize is that
just as important as our friendships during our 20s. But despite that, we really do struggle, you and I, both of us can acknowledge that we struggle to devote the necessary time to them, to doing our hobbies. We wish that we had more kind of things that we love to do in our free time. For me personally, I feel like I collect hobbies almost like their trinkets. Like I have so many hobbies on rotation that I adore and then I love doing. but I don't always get the chance to actually do them and, you know, I'll drop them every now and again and then pick them back up like six months later. And what I've really begun to realize is that|||在我们的20多岁时，和我们的友谊一样重要。但尽管如此，我们确实都在挣扎，你和我，我们两个都可以承认，我们在抽出必要的时间来做它们、进行我们的爱好时感到很挣扎。我们希望在空闲时间能有更多自己喜欢做的事情。就我个人而言，我觉得我收集爱好就像收集小饰品一样。我有那么多轮流进行的爱好，我都非常喜欢并且乐在其中。但我并不总是有机会真正去实行它们，而且，你知道的，我时不时会放下它们，然后大约六个月后又重新捡起来。我真正开始意识到的是
the times when I'm not actively doing my hobbies are the times when my life kind of suffers. Often it's that my life feels like it's all centered on work and my relationships and my responsibilities and we need something deeper than that. We need projects. We need creativity. We need to be using different parts of our brain and there are just so many benefits that hobbies bring. You think that something so small and so playful often and so fun couldn't be so powerful. But I think actually enjoying your life is one of those crucial, you know, secret parts of being healthier physically, of being more rounded and more interesting, fulfilled person. Hobbies play a big role in that.
the times when I'm not actively doing my hobbies are the times when my life kind of suffers. Often it's that my life feels like it's all centered on work and my relationships and my responsibilities and we need something deeper than that. We need projects. We need creativity. We need to be using different parts of our brain and there are just so many benefits that hobbies bring. You think that something so small and so playful often and so fun couldn't be so powerful. But I think actually enjoying your life is one of those crucial, you know, secret parts of being healthier physically, of being more rounded and more interesting, fulfilled person. Hobbies play a big role in that.|||当我没有积极进行我的爱好时，往往就是我的生活开始受挫的时候。通常情况下，我的生活感觉全都是围绕着工作、人际关系和责任打转，我们需要比这更深层次的东西。我们需要项目。我们需要创造力。我们需要动用大脑的不同部分，爱好带来的好处实在是太多了。你可能会认为，如此渺小、充满趣味且好玩的东西不可能具有那么强大的力量。但我认为，真正享受生活是保持身体健康、成为一个更全面、更有趣、更充实的人的关键秘诀之一。爱好在其中发挥了重要作用。
And it's so easy to see our well-being is like physical health, mental health, seeing friends. But having fun, being creative, doing something else with your time is significant. I also feel like hobbies are so great for reconnecting with your inner child. They make you feel curious. They're great for connecting with others. They use new parts of your brain that lay dormant whilst you're at work. You know, the list goes on. So today we're going to talk about the hidden psychological benefits.
And it's so easy to see our well-being is like physical health, mental health, seeing friends. But having fun, being creative, doing something else with your time is significant. I also feel like hobbies are so great for reconnecting with your inner child. They make you feel curious. They're great for connecting with others. They use new parts of your brain that lay dormant whilst you're at work. You know, the list goes on. So today we're going to talk about the hidden psychological benefits.|||我们很容易将幸福感视为身体健康、心理健康和与朋友见面。但寻找乐趣、发挥创造力、把时间花在别的事情上同样意义重大。我也觉得爱好对于重新连接你内心的童真大有裨益。它们能让你感到好奇。它们非常适合与他人建立联系。它们能动用你在工作时处于休眠状态的大脑新区域。你知道，这样的好处还有很多。所以今天我们要谈谈隐藏的心理益处
of hobbies that you may not know, the different types of hobbies, different categories of hobbies that are really actually quite fascinating when you get into it, and why it is that we struggle so much to get engaged in them. Why it is so much easier to consume, to watch television, to watch Instagram reels, to watch TikToks, why that has become the status quo, and how we can overcome the three major barriers that are stopping us from doing our hobbies. I am energized by this episode. I am excited by this episode. I want us all to leave, ready to try something new, to get your hands dirty, to get playful, get active, whatever it is. So without further ado, let's dive into all of the psychology behind why we need hobbies, especially in our 20s.
of hobbies that you may not know, the different types of hobbies, different categories of hobbies that are really actually quite fascinating when you get into it, and why it is that we struggle so much to get engaged in them. Why it is so much easier to consume, to watch television, to watch Instagram reels, to watch TikToks, why that has become the status quo, and how we can overcome the three major barriers that are stopping us from doing our hobbies. I am energized by this episode. I am excited by this episode. I want us all to leave, ready to try something new, to get your hands dirty, to get playful, get active, whatever it is. So without further ado, let's dive into all of the psychology behind why we need hobbies, especially in our 20s.|||你可能不知道的爱好的好处，不同类型的爱好，当你深入了解时其实相当迷人的不同爱好类别，以及为什么我们花那么多精力去参与它们却如此挣扎。为什么去消费、看电视、刷 Instagram 短视频、刷 TikTok 会容易得多，为什么这会成为现状，以及我们如何克服阻碍我们进行爱好的三大障碍。这集节目让我充满了活力。这集节目让我感到兴奋。我希望我们所有人听完后，都准备好尝试新事物，亲自动手，保持贪玩、积极，无论那是什么。闲话少说，让我们深入探讨为什么我们需要爱好（尤其是在20s）背后的所有心理学。
Let's begin with the basics, something so simple that it might seem silly. What is a hobby? What does that even mean in this day and age? That's where we really have to begin. And it's actually not a stupid question because surprisingly, the very definition of what makes up a hobby is up for debate. I think the debate is actually best summarized by whether you think watching movies is a hobby or not. because some people say, yes, of course it is. It's like quite educational.
Let's begin with the basics, something so simple that it might seem silly. What is a hobby? What does that even mean in this day and age? That's where we really have to begin. And it's actually not a stupid question because surprisingly, the very definition of what makes up a hobby is up for debate. I think the debate is actually best summarized by whether you think watching movies is a hobby or not. because some people say, yes, of course it is. It's like quite educational.|||让我们从基础开始，一件如此简单以至于显得有些愚蠢的事情。什么是爱好？在这个时代，这到底意味着什么？这正是我们必须要开始的地方。这其实并不是一个愚蠢的问题，因为令人惊讶的是，究竟什么是爱好，其定义本身就存在争议。我认为这场争议最好的总结，莫过于你是否认为看电影是一种爱好。因为有些人会说，是的，当然是。它相当具有教育意义。
You can get quite intellectual about it. And other people would be like, yeah, absolutely no way. That's way too passive to be a hobby. Think about your answer because it actually points to a really important distinction between what makes up a hobby and what does it. We can all agree that a hobby is something we do with our free time that we naturally enjoy. It also can't be related to what. work and some people would even say it can't be related to anything that you need to do, anything
You can get quite intellectual about it. And other people would be like, yeah, absolutely no way. That's way too passive to be a hobby. Think about your answer because it's actually points to a really important distinction between what makes up a hobby and what does not. We can all agree that a hobby is something we do with our free time that we naturally enjoy. It also can't be related to what. work and some people would even say it can't be related to anything that you need to do, anything|||你可以对它进行非常理性的探讨。而另一些人则会觉得：绝对不可能。这太被动了，算不上什么爱好。想想你的答案，因为它实际上指出了构成爱好与不构成爱好之间一个非常重要的区别。我们都可以赞同，爱好是我们利用空闲时间做的、自然而然会感到享受的事情。它也不能与工作相关，有些人甚至会说，它不能与任何你需要做的事情、任何
that is essential that you need for survival. So I love grocery shopping, right? And I do that in my free time, but it's not a hobby because it's something that is essential. So hobbies are their own unique form of, you know, leisure that is not purpose driven. The debate I mentioned before is also about whether a hobby requires some kind of effort or energy to be considered. a hobby. So there is very little mental effort that goes into being on your phone or scrolling or watching TV. And so people would say there's not an active commitment. You're not really getting something out because you're not putting anything in. But maybe, you know, foreign films at festivals would count because it does require some kind of cognitive expenditure. Hopefully that makes
that is essential that you need for survival. So I love grocery shopping, right? And I do that in my free time, but it's not a hobby because it's something that is essential. So hobbies are their own unique form of, you know, leisure that is not purpose driven. The debate I mentioned before is also about whether a hobby requires some kind of effort or energy to be considered. a hobby. So there is very little mental effort that goes into being on your phone or scrolling or watching TV. And so people would say there's not an active commitment. You're not really getting something out because you're not putting anything in. But maybe, you know, foreign films at festivals would count because it does require some kind of cognitive expenditure. Hopefully that makes|||生存所必需的事情相关。所以，我喜欢逛杂货店，对吧？我在空闲时间也会去，但这不算爱好，因为这是一件必不可少的事情。因此，爱好有其自身独特的、你知道的、非目标驱动的休闲形式。我前面提到的争论还在于，一项爱好是否需要投入某种努力或精力才能被视为爱好。因此，玩手机、刷手机或看电视所付出的脑力劳动极少。所以人们会说，这算不上积极的投入。你并没有真正从中获得什么，因为你没有付出什么。但也许，你知道的，电影节上的外国电影就算数，因为这确实需要某种认知消耗。希望这说得通
sense. It's really that debate around what crosses the line. And if you want my opinion, I'm a bit a hobby traditionalist. I do think that your hobbies kind of require something extra. They require you to like switch on your brain or your body or your creativity in a way that, you know, a passive act like watching TV or being on your phone doesn't. Like it's active. If you don't agree, obviously, I would love to hear from you because I know that there's differing opinions. But basically it's something that you find fun that you do in your leisure time that you do in your leisure time that you do regularly, which we'll get to later, and that uses some part of your brain or your body which is not related to work or something essential. Something really fascinating, at least I think
sense. It's really that debate around what crosses the line. And if you want my opinion, I'm a bit a hobby traditionalist. I do think that your hobbies kind of require something extra. They require you to like switch on your brain or your body or your creativity in a way that, you know, a passive act like watching TV or being on your phone doesn't. Like it's active. If you don't agree, obviously, I would love to hear from you because I know that there's differing opinions. But basically it's something that you find fun that you do in your leisure time that you do in your leisure time that you do regularly, which we'll get to later, and that uses some part of your brain or your body which is not related to work or something essential. Something really fascinating, at least I think|||这其实就是关于什么才算越界的争论。如果你想听我的意见，我算是一个爱好传统主义者。我确实认为你的爱好需要一些额外的东西。它们需要你以某种方式开启你的大脑、身体或创造力，而你知道，像看电视或玩手机这种被动行为则不需要。它必须是积极主动的。如果你不同意，当然，我很乐意听听你的想法，因为我知道大家有不同的意见。但基本上，它是你在闲暇时间觉得有趣的事情，你在闲暇时间定期去做的事情（我们稍后会讨论），并且它动用了你大脑或身体的某个部分，而这部分与工作或必需的事情无关。有一件非常迷人的事情，至少我认为
it's fascinating, but something fascinating that I discovered is about how certain people think about hobbies, especially sociologists, and how they group them. So there are actually three different types of hobbies or hobbyists, people who do hobbies. According to this book, which is a whole book on the psychology and the sociology of hobbies published in 2015, there is the casual leisure kind of hobby that is fun, you know, maybe short-lived, doesn't really require a lot of preparation or money. So like, you might go and play basketball at a community court once a week, or you swim at a local pool, you play board games, you make some kind of art like coloring in. That is casual leisure. Then we get a bit more serious. And this is very properly called serious leisure hobbies.
it's fascinating, but something fascinating that I discovered is about how certain people think about hobbies, especially sociologists, and how they group them. So there are actually three different types of hobbies or hobbyists, people who do hobbies. According to this book, which is a whole book on the psychology and the sociology of hobbies published in 2015, there is the casual leisure kind of hobby that is fun, you know, maybe short-lived, doesn't really require a lot of preparation or money. So like, you might go and play basketball at a community court once a week, or you swim at a local pool, you play board games, you make some kind of art like coloring in. That is casual leisure. Then we get a bit more serious. And this is very properly called serious leisure hobbies.|||这很迷人，但我发现的一件迷人的事是关于某些人（尤其是社会学家）如何看待爱好，以及他们如何对爱好进行分类。所以实际上有三种不同类型的爱好或爱好P（爱好者的意思），即从事爱好的人。根据2015年出版的这本关于爱好的心理学和社会学的专著，有一种是休闲式的爱好，很有趣，你知道的，可能比较短暂，实际上不需要太多的准备或金钱。所以，比如，你可能会一周去一次社区球场打篮球，或者你在当地的游泳池游泳，你玩桌游，你做一些像涂色这样的艺术创作。那是休闲娱乐。然后我们变得更严肃一点。这被恰如其分地称为严肃休闲爱好。
These are the kinds of hobbies that require a bit more effort, a bit more money as well to be rewarding. Like ceramics. There is, you do have to pay for the tools. You have to pay for the equipment or horse riding or scuba diving. It can also describe people who have taken a casual leisure hobby. So like bike riding and made it a lot more serious. You know, you can get a $50 secondhand bike on Facebook marketplace and like ride it around your neighborhood and that can be a hobby. Or for example, you know, I have a friend Felix who spends so much money on bikes and equipment and he does races and he has gels and outfits. Like, you know, he's at that serious leisure leisure.
These are the kinds of hobbies that require a bit more effort, a bit more money as well to be rewarding. Like ceramics. There is, you do have to pay for the tools. You have to pay for the equipment or horse riding or scuba diving. It can also describe people who have taken a casual leisure hobby. So like bike riding and made it a lot more serious. You know, you can get a $50 secondhand bike on Facebook marketplace and like ride it around your neighborhood and that can be a hobby. Or for example, you know, I have a friend Felix who spends so much money on bikes and equipment and he does races and he has gels and outfits. Like, you know, he's at that serious leisure leisure.|||这类爱好需要付出更多的努力，也需要更多的金钱才能获得回报。比如陶瓷。确实，你必须为工具付费。你必须为装备、骑马或水肺潜水付费. 它也可以用来形容那些将休闲爱好认真对待的人。比如骑自行车，并把它变得更严肃。你知道的，你可以在 Facebook 市场上买一辆 50 美元的二手自行车，然后在你的社区里骑，这可以是一个爱好。或者例如，你知道的，我有一个朋友菲利克斯，他在自行车和装备上花了很多钱，他参加比赛，他有能量胶和服装。就像，你知道的，他处于严肃休闲的水平。
level. I'm going to make an argument that even like a hobby like reading can become serious leisure. And we're seeing that more with like the popularity of book talk where like people build whole rooms for their books. They collect them. They have these long term yearly reading goals of like 100, 200 books. Like that has to cost money. And I was speaking to a friend about this recently who was saying and she's like a huge avid reader. and she was saying how that culture has really taken the fun out of reading and the fun of book clubs and of the community because it's not leisure anymore. It's almost like work. It's almost like competition amongst other people in the community. Just a quick sidebar.
level. I'm going to make an argument that even like a hobby like reading can become serious leisure. And we're seeing that more with like the popularity of book talk where like people build whole rooms for their books. They collect them. They have these long term yearly reading goals of like 100, 200 books. Like that has to cost money. And I was speaking to a friend about this recently who was saying and she's like a huge avid reader. and she was saying how that culture has really taken the fun out of reading and the fun of book clubs and of the community because it's not leisure anymore. It's almost like work. It's almost like competition amongst other people in the community. Just a quick sidebar.|||我要提出一个观点，甚至像阅读这样的爱好也可以变成严肃休闲。随着读书分享圈（book talk）的流行，我们越来越常看到这种情况，比如人们为自己的书建造整间屋子。他们收集图书。他们有诸如每年阅读 100 本、200 本书之类的长期年度阅读目标。这肯定是要花钱的。我最近和一个朋友谈过这件事，她是一个非常狂热的读者，她说这种文化真的剥夺了阅读的乐趣，以及读书俱乐部和社群的乐趣，因为它不再是休闲了。这几乎就像工作。这几乎就像是社区中其他人之间的竞争。插播一条简短的话题。
I thought that was very interesting. But finally, we have project-based leisure. That's our final category. And this is short term. It's often one-off projects that are rewarding. like building Lego sets, volunteering for sports events or like building a really elaborate garden. You know, you just, you can't do that every day. You might only do it like three to four times a year.
I thought that was very interesting. But finally, we have project-based leisure. That's our final category. And this is short term. It's often one-off projects that are rewarding. like building Lego sets, volunteering for sports events or like building a really elaborate garden. You know, you just, you can't do that every day. You might only do it like three to four times a year.|||我觉得这非常有趣。但最后，我们有基于项目的休闲。这是我们的最后一类。这是短期的。这通常是获得回报的一次性项目。比如拼乐高套装，为体育赛事做志愿者，或者建造一个非常精致的花园。你知道的，你不可能每天都这样做。你可能一年只做三到四次。
But it is still like an ongoing project based hobby. So that brings us to another fascinating debate. How many hobbies should you have and how often should you be doing them? this definitely like varies on age. I feel like we all have the experience of being a kid or a teenager and having seemingly like thousands of hobbies that are then replaced by work and replaced by like the other things that we need to do day in and day out as we get older. But then I think as we reach like an older age almost becoming elderly, all of our hobbies
But it is still like an ongoing project based hobby. So that brings us to another fascinating debate. How many hobbies should you have and how often should you be doing them? this definitely like varies on age. I feel like we all have the experience of being a kid or a teenager and having seemingly like thousands of hobbies that are then replaced by work and replaced by like the other things that we need to do day in and day out as we get older. But then I think as we reach like an older age almost becoming elderly, all of our hobbies|||但它仍然像是一个持续的、以项目为基础的爱好。这就把我们带到了另一个引人入胜的辩论中。你应该有多少个爱好？你应该多久进行一次？这绝对因年龄而异。我觉得我们都有过这样的经历：作为小孩子或青少年时，似乎有成千上万的爱好，随着年龄的增长，这些爱好随后被工作所取代，被我们日复一日需要做的其他事情所取代。但后来我认为，当我们达到老年，几乎成为老人时，我们所有的爱好
come back. And I am going to use the example of. my grandma as a prime opportunity to explain this, that woman is so busy. She is bustling. She is doing. She gardens. She paints. Volunteers. She reads. Bakes. Go to the gym. Even like 78. So it's kind of like it definitely differs across our lifespan. But if we are following the law of averages, researchers will typically say that two to five hobbies is the sweet spot. You should have between two to five things that you're really passionate about and then maybe a few other things that you do occasionally. So one study from 2010 that was actually the first of its kind. It basically
come back. And I am going to use the example of. my grandma as a prime opportunity to explain this, that woman is so busy. She is bustling. She is doing. She gardens. She paints. Volunteers. She reads. Bakes. Go to the gym. Even like 78. So it's kind of like it definitely differs across our lifespan. But if we are following the law of averages, researchers will typically say that two to five hobbies is the sweet spot. You should have between two to five things that you're really passionate about and then maybe a few other things that you do occasionally. So one study from 2010 that was actually the first of its kind. It basically|||又都回来了。我将以我奶奶为例来解释这一点，那个女人太忙了。她忙忙碌碌的。她一直在做事。她园艺。她画画。做志愿者。她读书。烘焙。去健身房。甚至都78岁了。所以这就像是它在整个人生阶段中肯定有所不同。但如果我们遵循平均法则，研究人员通常会说，两到五个爱好是最佳平衡点。你应该有两到五个你真正热衷的事情，然后可能还有其他一些你偶尔会做的事情。2010年的一项研究实际上是同类研究中的第一项。它基本上
tried to find the golden number for hobbies and fascinatingly, interestingly, shockingly, they found that the limit does not exist as long as you have the space and the time, the more hobbies you do, the more improvements you will see to your physical and psychological health. It's also associated with less stress, lower blood pressure. That's what having more hobbies and more leisure time brings you. I think the more leisure time is also an important factor. These are all things that, you know, we really want to say. So basically, as long as you have the space, you can have as many hobbies as you want and still be benefiting. There is another formula that you've probably heard as well. Another like golden number for hobbies. And that is the formula of four.
tried to find the golden number for hobbies and fascinatingly, interestingly, shockingly, they found that the limit does not exist as long as you have the space and the time, the more hobbies you do, the more improvements you will see to your physical and psychological health. It's also associated with less stress, lower blood pressure. That's what having more hobbies and more leisure time brings you. I think the more leisure time is also an important factor. These are all things that, you know, we really want to say. So basically, as long as you have the space, you can have as many hobbies as you want and still be benefiting. There is another formula that you've probably heard as well. Another like golden number for hobbies. And that is the formula of four.|||试图找出爱好的黄金数字，令人着迷、有趣、震惊的是，他们发现只要你有空间和时间，限制是不存在的，你做的爱好越多，你的身体和心理健康就会看到越多的改善。它还与更少的压力、更低的血压有关。这就是拥有更多爱好和更多休闲时间带给你的东西。我认为更多的休闲时间也是一个重要因素。这些都是你知道的我们真正想说的话。所以基本上，只要你有空间，你可以拥有尽可能多的爱好，并且仍然受益。还有另一个公式你可能也听说过。另一个关于爱好的黄金数字。那就是四的公式。
We need four hobbies. A hobby to keep you physically fit. A hobby to stay creative. A hobby to stay mentally fit. And a hobby to make money. I tried so hard to like try and figure out who said this first. I think nowadays it's just common wisdom. And I love the first. I love the first. I think that's the first three. My hobby to keep me fit is boxing in the gym and then I do ceramics to stay creative and I read and I listen to podcasts. I read journals to like keep myself mentally fit. But the last one, a hobby to make you money, I do have a small issue with including that because I think when you make money from a hobby, you lose the implicit natural enjoyment that is meant to bring. And I actually say that as someone who made one of their hobbies like a full-time job.
We need four hobbies. A hobby to keep you physically fit. A hobby to stay creative. A hobby to stay mentally fit. And a hobby to make money. I tried so hard to like try and figure out who said this first. I think nowadays it's just common wisdom. And I love the first. I love the first. I think that's the first three. My hobby to keep me fit is boxing in the gym and then I do ceramics to stay creative and I read and I listen to podcasts. I read journals to like keep myself mentally fit. But the last one, a hobby to make you money, I do have a small issue with including that because I think when you make money from a hobby, you lose the implicit natural enjoyment that is meant to bring. And I actually say that as someone who made one of their hobbies like a full-time job.|||我们需要四个爱好。一个让你保持身体健康的爱好。一个保持创造力的爱好。一个保持精神健康的爱好。还有一个赚钱的爱好。我非常努力地去弄清楚是谁最先说这句话的。我想现在这只是一般常识了。我喜欢第一个。我喜欢第一个。我想那是前三个。我保持身材的爱好是在健身房打拳击，然后我做陶瓷来保持创造力，我阅读并听播客。我阅读期刊来保持精神健康。但最后一个，一个赚钱的爱好，我对把它包括在内有一点小小的异议，因为我认为当你从爱好中赚钱时，你就失去了它本应带来的潜在的自然乐趣。我作为一个把自己的爱好变成全职工作的人，其实是深有体会的。
You know, this podcast used to be purely a leisure activity. I posted what I wanted not as frequently as I do now. It was just super random topics that I'd cover and I'd literally have my friends on as guests. And then a lot of you tuned in. Thank you for doing that. And it became my full-time job. This is what I want to say about that. And I want to caveat by saying, I absolutely love what I do.
You know, this podcast used to be purely a leisure activity. I posted what I wanted not as frequently as I do now. It was just super random topics that I'd cover and I'd literally have my friends on as guests. And then a lot of you tuned in. Thank you for doing that. And it became my full-time job. This is what I want to say about that. And I want to caveat by saying, I absolutely love what I do.|||你知道，这个播客以前纯粹是一种休闲活动。我发布我想发的内容，频率没有现在这么高。那只是我涉猎的超级随机的话题，我真的会让我的朋友作为嘉宾上节目。然后你们很多人都收听了。谢谢你们这样做。它成了我的全职工作。这就是我想说的。我想预先说明的是，我绝对热爱我所做的事情。
But when you start doing the things, that you used to do purely for enjoyment as a way to make money, you have got to love it at least like 200%. Because when money and finances get involved, it is naturally going to become stressful and you will lose, I would like to say, 100% of the love. So you have to be at a 200% level to afford to lose 100% of the love so that you're still full of passion for it. So you've, you know, you've still got to make sure you have that motivation. you're naturally going to lose that when it becomes a job. And it's really, really common that this happens, especially amongst people who are creators or musicians or people who are sports people,
But when you start doing the things, that you used to do purely for enjoyment as a way to make money, you have got to love it at least like 200%. Because when money and finances get involved, it is naturally going to become stressful and you will lose, I would like to say, 100% of the love. So you have to be at a 200% level to afford to lose 100% of the love so that you're still full of passion for it. So you've, you know, you've still got to make sure you have that motivation. you're naturally going to lose that when it becomes a job. And it's really, really common that this happens, especially amongst people who are creators or musicians or people who are sports people,|||但是，当你开始把那些你以前纯粹为了享受而做的事情当作赚钱的手段时，你必须以至少 200% 的热爱去对待它。因为当金钱和财务卷入其中时，它自然会变得压力重重，我想说，你会失去 100% 的爱。所以你必须达到 200% 的水平，才能经得起 100% 的爱意的消逝，这样你对它仍然充满激情。所以你，你知道，你仍然必须确保你有那种动力。当它变成一份工作时，你自然会失去那种感觉。这种情况非常非常普遍，尤其是在创作者、音乐人或体育界人士中，
athletes. I love that I didn't know the word for that. Athletes. For me, I, you know, I had like basically a hobby crisis when the podcast became my full-time job like almost two years ago now, because it was all I cared about. It was all I cared about. It was all I cared about. about it was the thing I really loved doing and then it became additionally my source of financial security or lack thereof and it made it pretty exhausting because additionally I think nothing had taken its place in my life as the thing that I just purely did for the pleasure of it. There was nothing leisure based that I was doing outside of this because it was taking a while for everything to kind of line up or kind of settle into place.
athletes. I love that I didn't know the word for that. Athletes. For me, I, you know, I had like basically a hobby crisis when the podcast became my full-time job like almost two years ago now, because it was all I cared about. It was all I cared about. It was all I cared about. about it was the thing I really loved doing and then it became additionally my source of financial security or lack thereof and it made it pretty exhausting because additionally I think nothing had taken its place in my life as the thing that I just purely did for the pleasure of it. There was nothing leisure based that I was doing outside of this because it was taking a while for everything to kind of line up or kind of settle into place.|||运动员。我很高兴我刚刚不知道那个词怎么说。运动员。对我来说，大约两年前播客成为我的全职工作时，我经历了一场“爱好危机”，因为这是我唯一关心的事。这是我唯一关心的事。这是我唯一关心的事。这是我真正喜欢做的事情，然后它又成了我的经济保障来源（或缺乏经济保障的来源），这让我感到非常疲惫，因为此外，我认为生活中没有什么能取代它成为我纯粹为了快乐而做的事情。除了这个之外，我没有做任何基于休闲的事情，因为这一切需要一段时间来理顺或安定下来。
And that is when I think I had this whole crisis of like, who am I? What do I even stand for that isn't work? And I made it a real thing that I was dedicating myself to. I was dedicating myself to my hobbies. I started pottery. I started swimming in the ocean again. I started boxing because I didn't want to lose myself any further in that process. So why do we need?
And that is when I think I had this whole crisis of like, who am I? What do I even stand for that isn't work? And I made it a real thing that I was dedicating myself to. I was dedicating myself to my hobbies. I started pottery. I started swimming in the ocean again. I started boxing because I didn't want to lose myself any further in that process. So why do we need?|||也就是在那时，我想我经历了整场危机：我是谁？除了工作，我究竟代表什么？我把它当作我真正投入的事情。我全身心地投入到我的爱好中。我开始做陶艺。我重新开始在大海里游泳。我开始练拳击，因为我不想在这个过程中进一步迷失自我。那么，为什么我们需要
need to do this? Why do we need to spend time, devote time, prioritize time for our hobbies? And speaking from a psychological, emotional, even physical perspective, what are the benefits? We are going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
need to do this? Why do we need to spend time, devote time, prioritize time for our hobbies? And speaking from a psychological, emotional, even physical perspective, what are the benefits? We are going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.|||需要这样做？为什么我们需要花时间、投入时间、优先为我们的爱好安排时间？从心理、情感甚至身体的角度来看，有哪些好处？我们在稍作休息后将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧的科学。我剖析了在这个奇特现代世界中培养心理坚韧、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等交谈，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.|||我们曾经坚信植物油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。世界上许多让我们感到恐慌的问题其实都是压力的结果. 让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。
On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.|||我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都在这里精选内容，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，滔滔不绝地谈论 80 年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，1984 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, I'm one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.|||我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.|||正值心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions.|||我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要？你当好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图。
bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies. In her story, this began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies. In her story, this began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.|||兄弟。完全同意。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们将就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出明显的矛盾之处。在她的故事中，这引发了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.|||成群的互联网侦探才破了这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税钱被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的规律。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马林西尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.|||这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm going to hold your hand when I say this, but your life will never, be truly fulfilling if all you have is work and your relationships. Both of those things are really crucial, but you need something that's just about you. You need more flavor. You need more excitement. That is what hobbies are for. Especially in our 20s, there is this very important developmental
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm going to hold your hand when I say this, but your life will never, be truly fulfilling if all you have is work and your relationships. Both of those things are really crucial, but you need something that's just about you. You need more flavor. You need more excitement. That is what hobbies are for. Especially in our 20s, there is this very important developmental|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当我这么说时，我会握着你的手（说句掏心窝子的话），但如果你的生活中只有工作和人际关系，你的生活将永远不会真正充实。这两件事确实都至关重要，但你需要一些完全属于你自己的东西。你需要更多的生活情调。你需要更多的刺激。这正是爱好的意义所在。特别是在我们20多岁的时候，有一个非常重要的发展
transition we experience where work becomes the predominant activity in our lives. And naturally, it takes over a lot of our identity. And that makes sense. If you're spent, eight hours plus at your job every day, that is a big chunk of your time that it's going to be consumed with whatever it is you're doing, data entry, talking to people, solving problems, helping people moving things, whatever it is. There was a really great article from Yale University that spoke about how this is particularly a problem for those of us who are relatively early on in our careers, because there's that implicit fear of failure that drives us to center our lives on work and achieving what is
transition we experience where work becomes the predominant activity in our lives. And naturally, it takes over a lot of our identity. And that makes sense. If you're spent, eight hours plus at your job every day, that is a big chunk of your time that it's going to be consumed with whatever it is you're doing, data entry, talking to people, solving problems, helping people moving things, whatever it is. There was a really great article from Yale University that spoke about how this is particularly a problem for those of us who are relatively early on in our careers, because there's that implicit fear of failure that drives us to center our lives on work and achieving what is|||我们经历的转型期是：工作成为我们生活中的主要活动。自然而然地，它占据了我们很大一部分身份认同。这很合乎逻辑。如果你每天在工作上耗费八个多小时，那么你很大一部分时间都将消耗在无论你做什么事情上，数据录入、与人交谈、解决问题、帮人搬运东西，无论那是什么。耶鲁大学有一篇非常棒的文章谈到，这对于我们这些职业生涯相对较早的人来说尤其是一个问题，因为那种对失败的隐秘恐惧驱使我们把生活中心放在工作上，以及实现
expected of us. This intense like drive and focus, it forces our identity to ultimately become synonymous with what we do for a living. I remember when I was working as a consultant, like someone asked me like two years into working this job, what do you do for fun? And I had to really think about it and then I had to make it up. because at that point, work was everything to me. Yes, I would like see my friends. I would go out for drinks. I would go out for dinner.
expected of us. This intense like drive and focus, it forces our identity to ultimately become synonymous with what we do for a living. I remember when I was working as a consultant, like someone asked me like two years into working this job, what do you do for fun? And I had to really think about it and then I had to make it up. because at that point, work was everything to me. Yes, I would like see my friends. I would go out for drinks. I would go out for dinner.|||对我们的期望。这种强烈的驱动力和专注力，迫使我们的身份最终与我们谋生的职业划上等号。我记得当我做顾问工作时，工作大约两年后有人问我，你平时有什么消遣？我不得不认真思考了一下，然后我不得不编造一个答案。因为在那时，工作就是我的全部。是的，我会见朋友。我会出去喝一杯。我会出去吃晚饭。
I'd go to the gym. But there wasn't much more. There wasn't much that was individual to me. And that is a big risk of not having hobbies. You stop being someone who has dimension. And that brings me to a huge benefit. Having a hobby, having a couple allows you to build. an intentional life outside of career and outside your work.
I'd go to the gym. But there wasn't much more. There wasn't much that was individual to me. And that is a big risk of not having hobbies. You stop being someone who has dimension. And that brings me to a huge benefit. Having a hobby, having a couple allows you to build. an intentional life outside of career and outside your work.|||我会去健身房。但除此之外没有太多别的了。没有什么是非常属于我个人的。这就是没有爱好的巨大风险。你不再是一个具有多面性的人。这就带给我一个巨大的好处：拥有一个或几个爱好，能让你在职业和工作之外建立起。一种有意识的生活。
Think of yourself and your life as like containing five buckets. You have your relationships, you have your work, your well-being, personal growth, and then you have fun, you have leisure. Your way to a balanced life is to pour as equally as you can into each of these buckets. But you kind of never get more water. So at any given time, the amount of water you have to distribute, across all these things is going to be the same. You can pour from one bucket into another. You can empty a bucket, but when these buckets are uneven, we suffer. If you keep pouring into the work
Think of yourself and your life as like containing five buckets. You have your relationships, you have your work, your well-being, personal growth, and then you have fun, you have leisure. Your way to a balanced life is to pour as equally as you can into each of these buckets. But you kind of never get more water. So at any given time, the amount of water you have to distribute, across all these things is going to be the same. You can pour from one bucket into another. You can empty a bucket, but when these buckets are uneven, we suffer. If you keep pouring into the work|||把自己和你的生活想象成包含五个桶。你有你的关系，你有你的工作，你的身心健康，个人成长，然后你有乐趣，你有休闲。过上平衡生活的秘诀，就是尽可能平等地将水注入这每一个桶中。但你基本上永远不会得到更多的水。所以在任何给定的时间，你必须分配到所有这些事情上的水量都是一样的。你可以把一个桶里的水倒进另一个桶里。你可以把一个桶倒空，但当这些桶里的水量不均时，我们就会痛苦。如果你一直往工作
bucket, you have to pour from the health bucket, you have to pour from the personal growth bucket, from your leisure bucket, your relationships will suffer. By having those hobbies that we enjoy and make time for, we balance out all the other buckets. We make sure that no, one bucket ever gets too big that it consumes all the liquid, all the water, all the energy. One study, for example, looked at the relationship between when you work really long hours and how that impacts depression and well-being. And on top of discovering the very obvious thing, which is that the more hours you work, the more significant negative impact it has on your health, what researchers did find was that
bucket, you have to pour from the health bucket, you have to pour from the personal growth bucket, from your leisure bucket, your relationships will suffer. By having those hobbies that we enjoy and make time for, we balance out all the other buckets. We make sure that no, one bucket ever gets too big that it consumes all the liquid, all the water, all the energy. One study, for example, looked at the relationship between when you work really long hours and how that impacts depression and well-being. And on top of discovering the very obvious thing, which is that the more hours you work, the more significant negative impact it has on your health, what researchers did find was that|||桶里注水，你就必须从健康桶里抽水，你必须从个人成长桶、休闲桶里抽水，你的人际关系就会受损。通过拥有那些我们喜爱并为其腾出时间的爱好，我们平衡了所有其他的桶。我们确保：没有任何一个桶会大到吞噬所有的液体、所有的水、所有的能量。例如，一项研究探讨了当你长时间工作时，这与抑郁和幸福感之间有什么关系。除了发现一个显而易见的事实（即工作时间越长，对健康的负面影响越显著）之外，研究人员还发现
having hobbies, even if you had limited time, actually helped mitigate those adverse side effects because you were still putting time, energy, you were making an investment in yourself as someone who was not just an employee. You know, you had this place to go where your brain can think about something different. It can de-stress. It can compartmentalize. That's also why I really often say that your hobbies should be different to what you do at work. or day, you know, like if you're a nurse, your hobby, this is going to sound silly, but it can't be like playing operation. You know, that's a silly example. But if you spend your day working in front of a screen doing like data or like marketing or whatever, you know, it's not
having hobbies, even if you had limited time, actually helped mitigate those adverse side effects because you were still putting time, energy, you were making an investment in yourself as someone who was not just an employee. You know, you had this place to go where your brain can think about something different. It can de-stress. It can compartmentalize. That's also why I really often say that your hobbies should be different to what you do at work. or day, you know, like if you're a nurse, your hobby, this is going to sound silly, but it can't be like playing operation. You know, that's a silly example. But if you spend your day working in front of a screen doing like data or like marketing or whatever, you know, it's not|||拥有爱好（即使你的时间有限）实际上有助于减轻这些不利的副作用，因为你仍然投入了时间、精力，你对作为一个不仅是雇员的自己进行了投资。你知道的，你有这样一个地方可以去，让你的大脑去思考一些不同的事情。它可以减压。它可以将思绪分门别类。这也是为什么我经常说，你的爱好应该不同于你在工作或日常中做的事情，你知道的，比如如果你是一名护士，你的爱好——这听起来可能有点傻——但不能像玩“外科手术”游戏一样。你知道，这是一个愚蠢的例子。但如果你一整天都在屏幕前工作，做数据或市场营销之类的事情，你知道的，这就不太好了
great if you come home and you have more screen-based hobbies. You want it to be quite nuanced. You want to give your brain something more to play with. You know, hobbies also just simply make you happier. We're just going to say it from the most basic psychological, lens. When you participate in something you love, your brain rewards you with dopamine. That keeps you motivated to keep going. It makes you happier. A life filled with hobbies feels more purposeful. One of my favorite, favorite, favorite pieces of research that supports this was conducted with almost, and I'm going to say this number because it's astounding 100,000 people. That's right. It was a piece of research on a hundred thousand people, all of them over the age of 65 and they'd all retired.
great if you come home and you have more screen-based hobbies. You want it to be quite nuanced. You want to give your brain something more to play with. You know, hobbies also just simply make you happier. We're just going to say it from the most basic psychological, lens. When you participate in something you love, your brain rewards you with dopamine. That keeps you motivated to keep going. It makes you happier. A life filled with hobbies feels more purposeful. One of my favorite, favorite, favorite pieces of research that supports this was conducted with almost, and I'm going to say this number because it's astounding 100,000 people. That's right. It was a piece of research on a hundred thousand people, all of them over the age of 65 and they'd all retired.|||如果你回到家还有更多基于屏幕的爱好。你希望它们非常微妙。你希望给你的大脑更多可以把玩的东西。你知道，爱好也能很简单地让你更快乐。我们只从最基础的心理学视角来说。当你参与你热爱的事情时，你的大脑会用多巴胺奖励你。这会让你保持继续前进的动力。它让你更快乐。充满爱好的生活感觉更有目标感。支持这一点的我最最最喜欢的一项研究，其调查对象几乎达到了——我要说出这个数字，因为它令人震惊——10万人。没错。这是一项针对 10 万人的研究，他们都超过 65 岁并且都已经退休了。
And what they found was that when these older adults had hobbies and they did their hobby more than once a week, they not only were happier, they also lived longer because health is not just physical. It is mental. It is cognitive. You will start giving up on your physical health, you will start not caring about yourself as much if you don't have something that you actually want to live for, something that you actually enjoy doing. You won't feel as positive towards yourself. You won't feel as positive towards your well-being and as active and protective if you don't feel like you have a purpose, if you're not happy. And you know, we don't need like a study to tell us that. Like intuitively, humans need recreational time. They need things to care about. But I do
And what they found was that when these older adults had hobbies and they did their hobby more than once a week, they not only were happier, they also lived longer because health is not just physical. It is mental. It is cognitive. You will start giving up on your physical health, you will start not caring about yourself as much if you don't have something that you actually want to live for, something that you actually enjoy doing. You won't feel as positive towards yourself. You won't feel as positive towards your well-being and as active and protective if you don't feel like you have a purpose, if you're not happy. And you know, we don't need like a study to tell us that. Like intuitively, humans need recreational time. They need things to care about. But I do|||他们发现，当这些老年人拥有爱好并且每周不止一次地进行他们的爱好时，他们不仅更快乐，而且活得更久，因为健康不仅是身体上的。它是精神上的。它是认知的。如果你没有一个你真正想为之活下去的东西，没有一个你真正喜欢做的事情，你就会开始放弃你的身体健康，你就会开始不再那么关爱自己。如果你觉得没有目标，不快乐，你对自己的感觉就不会那么积极。你对自己的幸福感就不会那么积极、活跃和具有保护意识。你知道，我们不需要什么研究来告诉我们这一点。凭直觉，人类需要娱乐时间。他们需要关心的事情。但我确实
think it's really important that I remind you. I'm just going to rattle off some other benefits. I know I've probably convinced you by now, but just quickly. Hobbies improve your focus. You know, even if you think, I don't have time for this, I'm so busy with work or school, like I'm not going to do my hobbies. I'm not going to go for a swim and not going to go to the gym and not going to do this, that, whatever. Actually, setting aside time to do those things will mean that you perform better anyways. They make you less stressed. They make you more in touch with your authentic self. And like depending on whether the activity is solo or group based as well, it can make you
think it's really important that I remind you. I'm just going to rattle off some other benefits. I know I've probably convinced you by now, but just quickly. Hobbies improve your focus. You know, even if you think, I don't have time for this, I'm so busy with work or school, like I'm not going to do my hobbies. I'm not going to go for a swim and not going to go to the gym and not going to do this, that, whatever. Actually, setting aside time to do those things will mean that you perform better anyways. They make you less stressed. They make you more in touch with your authentic self. And like depending on whether the activity is solo or group based as well, it can make you|||认为提醒你这一点非常重要。我只是顺便列举一些其他好处。我知道我可能已经说服你了，但简单说一下。爱好可以提高你的注意力。你知道，即使你认为，我没有时间做这个，我工作或上学太忙了，所以我不打算进行我的爱好。我不去游泳，不去健身房，也不做这、做那、无论什么。事实上，腾出时间去做这些事情意味着无论如何你都会表现得更好。它们能减轻你的压力。它们让你更贴近真实的自我。而且根据活动是独自进行还是以小组为单位，它还能让你
less lonely. It's a valuable part of our routine. It makes us more flexible. Every single thing points to us needing more time to do this. Scary finding though from the last few years is that this generation, you know, you and me people born after 1995, we are not picking up hobbies the same way people used to. We're seeing a steady decline in hobbyists, the people who have a lot of hobbies, who make hobbies a part of who they are.
less lonely. It's a valuable part of our routine. It makes us more flexible. Every single thing points to us needing more time to do this. Scary finding though from the last few years is that this generation, you know, you and me people born after 1995, we are not picking up hobbies the same way people used to. We're seeing a steady decline in hobbyists, the people who have a lot of hobbies, who make hobbies a part of who they are.|||不那么孤独。这是我们日常生活中有价值的一部分。它让我们更具灵活性。每一件事都表明我们需要更多的时间来做这件事。然而，过去几年的一个可怕发现是，这一代人，你知道的，你和我这些1995年以后出生的人，我们培养爱好的方式与过去的人不同了。我们看到爱好者的数量在稳步下降，那些拥有许多爱好、将爱好融入自我身份认同的人越来越少。
And a lot of our hobbies are based on consumption. So they are based on watching TV. They are based on collecting things that we have to buy, shopping, video games, movies, rather than production-based hobbies, production-based activities, things that are about. creating something new, expressing yourself, expending energy, giving something back. And it's not to say that certain hobbies are better or worse than others or like more pure, but I think if all our activities are attached to consumption and spending money, you know, it doesn't feel as fruitful. You don't actually feel like you're connecting in the same way with what you're doing. this probably comes down to a few things like this whole trend obviously like the rise in technology
And a lot of our hobbies are based on consumption. So they are based on watching TV. They are based on collecting things that we have to buy, shopping, video games, movies, rather than production-based hobbies, production-based activities, things that are about. creating something new, expressing yourself, expending energy, giving something back. And it's not to say that certain hobbies are better or worse than others or like more pure, but I think if all our activities are attached to consumption and spending money, you know, it doesn't feel as fruitful. You don't actually feel like you're connecting in the same way with what you're doing. this probably comes down to a few things like this whole trend obviously like the rise in technology|||并且我们的许多爱好都是基于消费的。所以它们基于看电视。它们基于收集我们必须购买的东西、购物、电子游戏、电影，而不是基于生产的爱好、基于生产的活动，那些关于创造新事物、表达自我、消耗精力、回馈社会的事情。这并不是说某些爱好比其他爱好更好或更糟，或者说更纯粹，但我认为如果我们的所有活动都与消费和花钱挂钩，你知道的，它就不会让人觉得那么硕果累累。你实际上不会觉得你正在以同样的方式与你所做的事情建立连接。这可能归结于一些事情，比如整个趋势，显然像是技术的兴起
is one of them like that is just what we are being fed screens are always at hand always available I don't think that they're like the devil that we think they are I think they're actually really important but you know our way of entertaining ourselves has shifted online I also think we are busier than ever. We have more commitments. We spend more time at work. There is less community fuel to our hobbies. This really sticks out to me. I think that people are craving in-person activities and community building, especially after the pandemic, because everything that we were doing became so solitary, meaning that we don't have the same social motivation to do them. It is why, personal opinion, book clubs, meetups, social sports, so special, but also so much more popular.
is one of them like that is just what we are being fed screens are always at hand always available I don't think that they're like the devil that we think they are I think they're actually really important but you know our way of entertaining ourselves has shifted online I also think we are busier than ever. We have more commitments. We spend more time at work. There is less community fuel to our hobbies. This really sticks out to me. I think that people are craving in-person activities and community building, especially after the pandemic, because everything that we were doing became so solitary, meaning that we don't have the same social motivation to do them. It is why, personal opinion, book clubs, meetups, social sports, so special, but also so much more popular.|||就是其中之一，就像那是我们一直在接触的东西，屏幕总是触手可及，随时可用。我不认为它们像我们想象的那样是魔鬼，我认为它们实际上非常重要，但你知道的，我们的娱乐方式已经转移到了线上。我也觉得我们比以往任何时候都忙。我们有更多的承诺。我们在工作上花更多的时间。我们的爱好缺乏社区的动力。这真的很让我触动。我认为人们渴望面对面的活动和社区建设，尤其是在大流行之后，因为我们所做的一切都变得如此孤立，这意味着我们没有同样的社交动机去做这些事情。这就是为什么，个人观点，读书俱乐部、聚会、社交体育如此特别，同时也如此受欢迎的原因。
I want to talk about how we can make our hobbies a priority, even in our busy lives, even when we're burnt out, even when it's so much easier to like turn on the TV or scroll on TikTok. How do we find the time? How do we make the time more importantly? We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
I want to talk about how we can make our hobbies a priority, even in our busy lives, even when we're burnt out, even when it's so much easier to like turn on the TV or scroll on TikTok. How do we find the time? How do we make the time more importantly? We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,|||我想谈谈我们如何才能将爱好放在首位，即使在忙碌的生活中，即使在我们筋疲力尽的时候，即使打开电视或刷 TikTok 要容易得多。我们如何找到时间？更重要的是，我们如何腾出时间？在稍作休息后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在这个奇特现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等交谈。
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
去抛开那些不切实际、过于复杂、充斥着养生行业的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们错了。世上许多让我们恐慌的问题，其实都源于压力。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你在另一端就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听 2%。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 T-W-O-Percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of Congress.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈 80 年代的快克毒品。说清楚点，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为国会。
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
快克。我随时都能聊聊快克，不过让大家知道一下。我的意思是，说到这儿，这已经是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为还有比这更重要的一年了，对黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Look Back at It。
Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要？你们做一个好人是因为你们害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中明显的不一致之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这就引发了一场长达数年的官司来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吧，斯内尔斯女士？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一种令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I want you to pause for a second and ask yourself an important question. How many hobbies do you actually have? Like, that you regularly do more than once a fortnight and how often are you actually doing them? A lot of us might come up with a few things, maybe nothing.
在亚利桑那州。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。我想让你停顿一下，问自己一个重要的问题。你到底有多少爱好？比如，你每两周定期进行一次以上的爱好，你实际上多久做一次？我们很多人可能会想出几样东西，或者什么也没有。
I think that is the major problem we're facing here. We like to think that we're doing our hobbies, but actually they tend to fall of our prioritization, our to-do list. Something I've seen a lot recently is like, even within myself, being like, oh yeah, I love reading, I love hiking, I love rock climbing. And then you go back through your recent memories and you're like, I can't actually remember the last time I did those things. Can't remember when I last finished a book,
我认为这是我们在这里面临的主要问题。我们总觉得自己有在进行爱好，但实际上它们往往排在了我们优先事项和待办事项列表的末尾。我最近经常注意到的一点是，甚至在我自己身上也是这样，会想：哦，是的，我喜欢阅读，我喜欢远足，我喜欢攀岩。然后你回想一下最近的记忆，就会觉得：我其实记不清我最后一次做这些事情是什么时候了。记不清我上次读完一本书是什么时候了，
when I went on a nice hike for the weekend. I think it comes down to three major problems. Firstly, there is a genuine lack of time. You know, life is really busy at the moment. We've got places to go. We've got people to see. A lot of us are embracing hustle culture and when there always seems to be something more urgent to do,
什么时候进行过一个美好的周末远足。我觉得这归结为三个主要问题。首先，确实缺乏时间。你知道，现在的生活真的很忙。我们有要去的地方。我们有要见的人。我们很多人都在拥抱拼搏文化，当似乎总有更紧急的事情要做时，
you just don't have the same capacity time-wise for your hobbies. That's problem one, a very serious problem. problem two is that we just think we don't have enough time but actually we do we just don't have the motivation number two a lack of motivation this is often linked to procrastination which we know can also come down to perfectionism like i can't do my hobbies because i'm not as good as other people are i'm not as good as the people i see in the studio online at the gym that's what gets in our way or we just don't prioritize our hobbies because there is something easier to do, something easier that we want to do, like maybe scroll on our phones, whatever, that gives us that instant dopamine and that instant gratification,
你在时间上对爱好的投入就力不从心了。这是第一个问题，一个非常严重的问题。第二个问题是，我们只是觉得自己没有足够的时间，但实际上我们有，我们只是缺乏动力。第二点，缺乏动力。这通常与拖延症有关，而我们知道拖延症也可以归结为完美主义。比如，我不能进行我的爱好，因为我没有其他人那么优秀，我没有工作室里、网上、健身房里看到的人那么优秀。这才是阻碍我们的原因。或者我们只是没有把爱好放在首位，因为有更容易做的事情，有我们想做的更容易的事情，比如在手机上刷社交媒体等等，这能给我们带来即时的多巴胺和即时的满足感，
whereas pursuing our hobbies takes more of a time investment to get the reward. You may start out your night, like wanting to do some painting or like wanting to do something fun, But then pretty soon you get pulled in by your phone. It's 10pm. It's time for bed. That is a really common dilemma. Something interesting that I found in some research conducted in the UK a few years ago is that our failure to do our hobbies is actually a cycle that comes back to motivational fatigue or a motivational deficit
而追求我们的爱好则需要更多的投资时间才能获得回报。你可能在刚开始一晚时，想要画画或者做一些有趣的事情，但很快你就会被手机吸引。晚上10点到了。该睡觉了。这是一个非常普遍的困境。我在几年前在英国进行的一项研究中发现了一个有趣的事情，那就是我们未能坚持爱好，实际上是一个循环，它回到了动机疲劳或动机赤字，
whereby our hobbies would actually motivate us to do them more. But the more we don't do them, the less motivated we, become. So really the hardest step when you've fallen off your hobbies, when you've stopped doing them, the hardest step is the first one, you know, just doing the thing, just committing, despite all the other distractions. That is where you're going to struggle the most. But then you get the motivation, you get the wheel rolling again. I think that's like any habit. It's always hard at the beginning, like the first five minutes of a run, the first hour of starting an assignment. there is just like so much time ahead of you, it just feels so long.
在这种状态下，我们的爱好实际上会激励我们更多地去做它们。但我们越是不去做，我们的动力就会越少。所以事实上，当你荒废了爱好、不再去做了之后，最难的一步就是第一步，你知道的，就是去做这件事，就是去坚持，不顾所有其他的干扰。那是你挣扎最厉害的时候。但随后你就会获得动力，让车轮重新转动起来。我觉得这就像任何习惯一样。一开始总是很难，就像跑步的前五分钟，开始一份作业的前一个小时，
But then you get going, it becomes more enjoyable. That is the motivational process of doing your hobbies more regularly. Finally, it may be that actually those hobbies that you've fallen away from, they just aren't fun anymore. They're just not something that you want to do. We're not particularly keen on doing them. I remember trying so hard to like be into rock climbing back in the day and make that my new hobby.
前面有那么多时间，感觉时间好漫长。但只要你开始动起来，就会变得更有趣。这就是更有规律地进行爱好的动机形成过程。最后，可能是因为你已经疏远的那些爱好，它们其实已经不再有趣了。它们不再是你想要做的事情了。我们并不是特别热衷于做它们。我记得当年曾非常努力地想要喜欢上攀岩，并把它当作我的新爱好。
I even had like the shoes and everything. I just couldn't force it. I couldn't do it. It was like trying to fit into the wrong relationship. I think at those points, obviously you're not going to want to participate. But you still have this like almost hypothetical like fake faux idea in your mind that that is still an active hobby for you when you haven't done it in like years, maybe even months. Maybe it's time to start something new.
我甚至连鞋子和其他装备都买齐了。我就是没办法勉强自己。我做不到。这就好像是在强行融入一段错误的感情。我想到了那个时候，很显然你不会想去参与。但你脑海里仍然有这样一种几乎是假设的、虚假的、假装的观念，认为那仍然是你的一个活跃爱好，而你其实已经好几年、甚至好几个月没碰过了。也许是时候开始一些新东西了。
Maybe it's time to refresh the hobby. be roster. And that brings me to the final reason that you're not doing your hobbies, it's because you're not excited about them. It's because you lack inspiration. Let's address that issue first, because I actually think that is the biggest culprit of all these reasons. I want to give you some ideas of some hobbies that you maybe haven't considered. I think we're all pretty used to the basic hobbies that people will list. And if you're not really into running or reading, Sometimes it's like, well, kind of what else is out there, but fear not. There are so many other things out there.
也许是时候更新你的爱好清单了。这就引出了你没有进行爱好的最后一个原因，那就是你对它们不感兴趣。因为你缺乏灵感。我们先解决这个问题，因为我实际上认为这是所有这些原因中最大的罪魁祸首。我想给你介绍一些你可能没有考虑过的一些爱好。我想我们都已经习惯了人们会列出的那些基本爱好。如果你真的不怎么喜欢跑步或阅读，有时就会觉得：嗯，那还有什么其他的选择呢？但别害怕。外面还有那么多别的东西。
I want to give you some of that inspiration you might be lacking. You could go shell collecting. Maybe your hobby is to go to the beach once a week, have a swim and find some shells and make cool jewelry out of them. Like make cool ceramic dishes using the shells. Baking for a new person each week. I was really into this a few years ago, like each week. I would choose someone new, like my neighbors, my roommates, some person I was going over to have dinner with, and I would make a new recipe for them.
我想给你提供一些你可能缺少的灵感。你可以去收集贝壳。也许你的爱好是每周去一次海滩，游游泳，找一些贝壳，用它们做漂亮的饰品。比如用贝壳制作精美的陶瓷盘子。每周为新做的一道菜烘焙。我几年前非常喜欢这个，比如每周。我会选择一个新的人，比如我的邻居、我的室友、某个我要去他家吃晚饭的人，然后为他们制作一篇新食谱。
Join a social sport team that, like, plays a new sport every week. I used to do this last year. It was super, super fun. Letter writing, you could make, like, really beautiful letters for your family or, like, your internet friends or, like, your long-distance college friends and send them back and forth. Hosting, you could host, like, a little dinner party every Sunday as, like, your hobby is literally hosting. Like your hobby is to create nice events for people to come and like hang out together.
加入一个社交运动队，每周玩一项新的运动。我去年经常这样做。真的超级超级有趣。写信，你可以为你的家人、你的网友或者你的远距离大学朋友写一些非常漂亮的信，然后寄给他们。举办派对，你可以每星期天举办一个小型晚宴，把举办派对当作你的爱好。就像你的爱好是创造美好的活动，让大家聚在一起，一起闲逛。
Make a little veggie patch or a garden that you tend to or a bonsai tree. Go to a ceramics class. I'm doing this currently. Actually, I've done three now and they're all like six weeks long. So you have to keep going because you pay at the beginning and you've committed knitting. This is one of my favorites. It sounds so like grandma core. But when you get into it, you can like sit and listen.
弄一个小小蔬菜园或花园来打理，或者种一棵盆景树。去上陶瓷课。我现在正在上这个。实际上，我已经上了三门了，它们都是六周长的。所以你必须坚持去，因为你在开始时就已经付过钱并且做出了承诺。织毛衣。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。听起来很像老奶奶风格。但当你深入其中时，你可以坐下来听，
into a podcast and just get so stuck into it. There's also people who like upcycle, which I love. That's something that me and my boyfriend Tom do, like once a week. We might go for a little walk around our neighborhood. Maybe this is just like an Australian thing, but people leave stuff out on the street all the time for like people to take with like little notes. So they'll have like, you know, everyone will have like a little box of stuff that people put things in and I don't know.
听播客，然后深深地沉迷其中。还有人喜欢旧物改造，我超喜欢。这是我和我男友汤姆每周大约做一次的事。我们可能会在我们的街区周围散步。也许这只是澳大利亚特有的现象，人们总是把东西留在街上，带上小纸条，供别人拿走。所以每个人都会有一个小盒子，里面放着各种东西，我也不知道。
It's just some people call it. garbage, I think it's treasure. You know, you could start a podcast, just like documenting your life and learning how to do all the sound editing and the uploading and the publishing and just not even tell anyone, it's just going to be like your own personal audio journal. There is just so much out there. That's really what I want to remind you. There is a lot that you can do. You might just need to invest a little bit of time to get things off the ground and to feel excited by it and that kind of brings me to my next barrier which is a lack of motivation. This is probably the hardest one to overcome if a lack of inspiration is the most common.
有些人称之为垃圾，我认为那是宝藏。你知道，你可以开一个播客，记录你的生活，学习如何进行所有的音频剪辑、上传和发布，甚至不告诉任何人，它就像是你自己的个人音频日志。外面有太多的东西可供探索。这正是我想要提醒你的。你其实可以做很多事情。你可能只需要投入一点点时间，让事情步入正轨，并对它感到兴奋，这这就引出了我的下一个障碍，那就是缺乏动力。如果缺乏灵感是最常见的障碍，
A lack of motivation is the hardest. I think if you're in this position, you need to treat the next month as like an exploration phase for you. So like set a personal challenge, set a goal to just try heaps of new things. Even if you don't have high expectations. make it like a way to socialize. Like instead of drinks, go and like get a jewelry making set or like go and get a puzzle. Do a board games night at a pub.
那么缺乏动力就是最难克服的。如果你处于这种境地，你需要把接下来的一个月当作你的探索阶段。所以设定一个个人挑战，设定一个目标去尝试大量的新事物。即使你对结果不抱太高的期望。把它当作一种社交方式。比如不要去喝酒，而是去买一套做首饰的工具，或者去买一个拼图。在酒吧举办一个桌游之夜。
Go for a hike. You don't have to commit to anything. All you're required to do is to have a taste. It's to just have a little palate cleanse. It's to just fill your days with activities rather than just lounging passive consumption. On another note, returning to your own. old hobbies often does start with just remembering why they brought you so much joy in the first place. We can forget that.
去远足。你不必承诺任何事情。你所需要做的只是去尝尝鲜。这就像给味蕾做个清爽的净化。让你的生活充满各种活动，而不是躺着消极地消费。另外，回归你自己的旧爱好通常也是从回想它们最初为什么能带给你如此多的快乐开始的。我们往往会忘记这一点。
It's very easy to lose touch with the things you love when life gets busy or when other priorities take over. But hobbies are a form of self-care. Think about how great you always feel afterwards. Even if you have to kind of like mentally drag yourself to the starting line, be like, okay, I'm going to let myself watch TV in 20 minutes. But before I do that, the same way that I make time to exercise, I make time to clean my house, I make time to talk to my friends,
当生活变得忙碌或者其他优先事项占据主导地位时，很容易与你热爱的事物失去联系。但爱好是一种自我关爱。想想你在事后总是感觉有多棒。即使你必须在精神上把自己拖到起跑线上，告诉自己：好吧，我允许自己在20分钟后看电视。但在那之前，就像我腾出时间锻炼、腾出时间打扫房子、腾出时间跟朋友聊天一样，
I'm going to make time to do my hobbies as a part of my hygiene routine as a part of my wellness routine. This, look at this perfect segue into talking about a lack of time because that is another big conundrum, another big problem, that we hear a lot. I hate to say it, and I'm going to be very gentle when I say it, but we can always make time for what we care about. And just to prove that, I want you to just think about your screen time for a second. How many 10, 20 minute increments do we have each day that instead we spend scrolling or watching? You know, you could switch that up. You could make
我要腾出时间来培养我的爱好，作为我卫生习惯的一部分，作为我健康保养routine的一部分。看，这是一个完美的过渡，让我们来谈谈缺乏时间，因为那是另一个大难题，另一个大我常听到的普遍问题。我很遗憾这么说，而且我在说这句话时态度会非常温和，但我们总是能为我们在乎的事情挤出时间。为了证明这一点，我想让你花一秒钟想想你的屏幕时间。我们每天有多少个10分钟、20分钟的碎片时间，却都花在了刷手机或看视频上？你知道的，你可以改变这种状况。你可以腾出
time for something else, even if it's small, even if it doesn't initially feel significant. Think about like when you're on the train. I saw this woman the other day knitting. She was only on for like four stops, but she pulled out her knitting needles and she was making, I don't really know what she was making. It looked really, really amazing though. You could bring your book and your goal for the next month is to, instead of go on your phone on your 20 minute commute on the bus or on the train, is to read. Try and find small pockets of time just because it doesn't feel like it's an extended hour or two hours doesn't mean that it's not a significant investment because the habit is really being built. I also think try and reframe the activity,
时间去做别的事情，哪怕它很小，哪怕它最初看起来并不重要。想想你在火车上的时候。我前几天看到一个女人在织毛衣。她只坐了大概四站路，但她拿出了织针，在织着，我其实不知道她在织什么。不过看起来真的很惊艳。你可以带上你的书，你下个月的目标是，在坐公交车或火车的20分钟通勤路上，不玩手机，而是去读书。试着寻找微小的时间碎片，仅仅因为它看起来不像是一个小时或两个小时的超长延伸，并不意味着这不是一个意义重大的投入，因为习惯正在真正建立起来。我还认为，试着重新构架这项活动，
not as an obligation, but as like something that you have the privilege of doing, something you want to do, it's a chance to unwind, it's a chance to explore, it's a chance to have real fun, like real true enjoyment, taking real true enjoyment from something that you're doing. And you'll notice like when you fall asleep at the end of the day, you're like, wow, I just feel so much more fulfilled. Because I didn't do what was easiest. I did what I knew was going to fill my cup the most, which was my hobbies. You can notice that change. Give yourself just 30 minutes a day to prioritize this. Even if it's not on all days, you're allowed to obviously have breaks. We can't all be disciplined with new habits. But ask yourself, at the end of the day, when you've tried these things, do what?
不要把它当成一种义务，而是把它当成一种你有特权去做的事情，你想做的事情，这是一个放松的机会，一个探索的机会，一个获得真正乐趣的机会，真正纯粹的快乐，从你正在做的事情中获得真正的快乐。你会注意到，当你一天结束时入睡，你会想：哇，我感觉充实多了。因为我没有选择最轻松的事。我做了我知道最能充实自己内心的事，那就是我的爱好。你能注意到这种变化。每天给自己30分钟的时间来优先处理这件事。即使不是每天都这样，你当然也可以休息。我们不可能对新习惯一直都那么自律。但问问自己，在一天结束时，当你尝试了这些事情之后，会怎样？
I feel better? Do I feel better? And the days that I have the time, but I choose not to do them, am I going to feel worse? And is that something that I've kind of allowed myself to feel? Knowing that I could have done something that was going to make me feel more energized and inspired and happier, choosing not to do that. That was a choice I made. And I could make a different choice next time. I could do something that actually fills my cup, makes me interested, makes me interesting, like, me happy, fulfilled, someone who has nuance, someone who has dimension to them, who isn't just work and responsibility. So I do know it's really, really hard. I'm saying this to someone who's definitely struggled with this as I've gotten older. There's just less pieces of the pie
我感觉好些了吗？我感觉好些了吗？在我有时间却选择不去做的那些日子里，我会感觉更糟糕吗？这算是我纵容自己去感受的一种糟糕状态吗？明知道我可以做一些能让我更有活力、更有灵感、更快乐的事情，却选择不去那样做。那是我的选择。下次我可以做出不同的选择。我可以做一些真正能充实内心、让我感兴趣、让我变得有趣的事情，让我快乐、充实，让我成为一个有内涵、有立体感的人，而不只是工作和责任。所以我确实知道这真的非常非常难。我对那些随着年龄增长、也确实在为此苦恼的人说这些话。生命中的蛋糕只有那么大，
to give out. And it's always like a, it's always like a balancing act of like what part of my life, what bucket is going to get more from me. But I do think that this is the bucket we should be pouring more into than we actually are. Hobbies are spectacular. They're amazing. They're so valuable for your 20s. So I just hope this has inspired you to get back into something that used to bring you a lot of joy and a lot of freedom and that you just really love doing, whether it's music, sport, art, whatever it is. Find a way back to it. See how your life improves. Hopefully you enjoyed this episode. If you did, please, feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now.
能够分出去的份额就更少了。这总是一个权衡的过程，看看我生活的哪一部分、哪一个领域需要我投入更多。但我确实认为，这正是我们应该倾注更多心血的领域，远远超过我们目前的投入。爱好真是太棒了。它们令人惊叹。对你的20岁来说太有价值了。所以我只希望这能激励你重新拾起曾经带给你很多快乐和自由、并且你真的很喜欢做的事情，无论是音乐、运动、艺术，还是别的什么。找回通往它的路。看看你的生活是如何改善的。希望你喜欢这一集。如果你喜欢，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。
I say it every time, but it does help the show grow, meet new people, reach new people, sorry, and I do read every single one of your reviews. They often end up in my little smile file. They're often the thing that I feel very grateful for at the end of the day. So thank you for the support if you have done so already. If you have an episode suggestion, questions, follow-ups to this episode, you can DM me at that psychology podcast. We would love to hear from you as always.
我每次都这么说，但这确实有助于节目成长、结识新朋友，抱歉，是触及新朋友，而且我确实会阅读你们的每一条评论。它们最后往往会进入我的小微笑档案。它们通常是我在一天结束时感到非常感激的事情。所以如果你已经这么做了，感谢你的支持。如果你有剧集建议、问题或对这一集的后续反馈，你可以在该心理学播客的私信中联系我。和往常一样，我们非常期待听到你的声音。
And until next week, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
在下周之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Snellins, correct? I doctored the test once.
有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，斯内尔斯女士，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same. same thing. Greg a lesbian. Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这就是走楼梯的人的比例，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the number. signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在旁边还有自动扶梯可用的时候。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了这个数字。它标志着精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你在另一端就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 2%。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证是由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。